when you have gone to youtube when was  the last time you did that and what did  you call up  it's a great question i probably did it  yesterday actually i do  you know i remember  being in college and when you go through  shooting slump you just pull up you know  the video guys would  pull up a great game of when everything  seemed in unison your body was working  so well and  that ball was just flowing off your  fingertips  and  uh gosh  i'll probably just youtube game six clay  because  there's some very high pressurized  situations i was in and i ended up  shooting the ball well and  when you can do it when your back's  against the wall you know you can do it  at any given moment it's just about  keeping that  mental strong